[Music]
[Applause]
let's get to rebecca lowe she's got
things to do nbc sports premier league
host
ahead of the season kickoff why why does
this say the season lick-off todd
oh that's a mistake on my point it
should say kickoff it says the season
lick-off is it really tomorrow afternoon
on usa well the k and the l are very
they're right next to each other on the
keyboard paulie am i being serious no
it's on the prep sheet it definitely
says let go the lick off
it's a very special soccer match now i
you know i don't understand all the
terminology with soccer in the premier
league rebecca is this a lick-off
tomorrow yeah yeah it is
it's a new thing it's a lick-off i mean
i would go into detail
your show is at the wrong time of day
okay
but it's like you know the the darby
there are certain you know words that i
use that i'm not allowed to use and it's
not derby it's a derby
yeah unless you're me on the kentucky
derby coverage where i was so good up
until right at the end and then a derby
came out and i was like in my head all i
could see was my boss's face hold on no
he's gonna kill me he's gonna kill me
the uh the kentucky darby you called it
oh i did i tried i did it's not okay is
it it's not i'm an american citizen you
know that i need to do better
uh you're in your kitchen did you do all
the dishes or all the dishes well i
i logged in to you guys and i was like
okay i'm gonna be two minutes i've just
got to undo the dishwasher it's the last
week of school holidays a lot going on
child care i mean there's just a lot
going on in this okay
we we appreciate you joining us the one
big question you have
going into this year with the premier
league this season is what
is manchester united or ah i should say
are manchester united going to
redeem themselves and return to a club
worthy of their history or are they
going to continue where they've gone for
the last nine years of our coverage
which is
fairly abysmal
i had the odds to win the premier league
according to draftkings
you want to guess
the city
city man city
liverpool yep
this next one's interesting i'm going to
have to probably go chelsea
no
tottenham yeah
yeah okay
and then manchester united
really and then arsenal
yes
well that's not going to happen okay
well i mean you never know they spent a
lot of money too but yeah united's fifth
favorite i mean that's not where
manchester united should be so my big
question they've got a new manager he's
already got a big problem with cristiano
ronaldo who wants to leave but nobody
wants him um why does he want to leave
because manchester united didn't qualify
for the champions league so they're not
going to be playing at that top echelon
of european football and cristiano
ronaldo
cares a lot about appearances goals and
and assists at
champions league level he's played at
every season of his career he does not
at the age of whatever he is 37 want
messi to overtake his records that's
really now what he cares about and
united aren't playing in the champions
league so he'd like to go but i'm
wondering about this that i don't know
if we talk about good teammates
in the premier league like we do in our
sports here in the united states where
hey he's not a good clubhouse guy he's
not a good locker room guy or he's a
leader ronaldo seems to be
ronaldo
but but but can that is that a wrong
wrong way to define ronaldo i i think
you're not i don't think you're wrong
dan i think as the years have gone by
and he gets to an age
where he's running out of time he
becomes more about ronaldo in england
our phrase is are you bigger than the
club nobody is bigger than the club and
in ronaldo's case there's an argument
that he is bigger than manchester united
and he knows it and he has not been a
good teammate in fact he played i think
a few minutes in a game on sunday in a
friendly and he left the stadium before
the end of the game the new manager is
not happy he's had words with him
and this is not a good way to start a
new season but you're right ronaldo at
the moment is about ronaldo could you
see a salary cap
with the premier league
no
no i can't i think i think
it would stop certain players coming it
would change the whole face i
i just
i don't i don't think that will happen i
think it's too successful why change
something i mean i don't get me wrong
500 000 quid a week is insane but it's
um they're the best in the world they're
the best in the world and what they do
you've got to pay them the best in the
world at what they do and that's okay i
think that's okay
i just want my my uh squad uh leads
united to have a chance
sorry sorry i thought
sorry my bad i for many a year i really
thought you were a hard and fast
manchester city fan now did that change
well i was leicester city
oh leicester ireland
yeah you were like you okay now you're
gonna mock me and i didn't mock you
about the kentucky darby and i said
leicester city and you go dan it's
leicester city yeah yeah i did i did i
have to now it's not like you said oh
this horse is going to win the kentucky
darby
like like i did leicester city i got
them winning the premier league
i know but it's so fun i have to mock
you it's just what we do every time i
come on um leeds united is that because
they have an american manager is that
where you like them now yeah okay
i watched the documentary i watched the
documentary okay great
brownie points i do think that that
manager there is a chance he may not be
there uh come the end of november so you
may have to have a reevaluation because
don't forget the world cup is coming so
there's a six week gap that's never been
which is gonna be the six week gap is
gonna be the time where owners are like
okay we've got six weeks let's fire the
manager let's go so he he's got a tough
one he's lost a lot of good players
jessie marsh i think you may have picked
a dodgy one i'm not gonna lie
well i can i can go back to leicester
city you can and i'm sure there was a
manchester city in there at one year but
there was 13 yeah there was so and
that's okay you can flip that's
corporate that's too corporate yeah i
don't want to be the corporate uh
christian pulisic how important is this
season for him
i mean it's massive but it's concerning
he he i'm not sure he particularly wants
to be there anymore his dad came out on
twitter at the end of last season sort
of hinting that pallisic wanted out
because he wasn't starting games but the
guy gets injured a lot so it's difficult
to get a run in the team because he gets
injured and then it's difficult for the
manager to know whether or not he can
trust him so they've bought a few
players which will challenge his
position pulisic and he he's fine for
the world cup obviously he's a shoe-in
for the u.s men's national team that's
not a problem i
something big has to happen he has to
have a brilliant first couple of months
of the season
for him to come off the table of
conversation at the moment he's on the
table of conversation as in
is this going to be his last year a at
chelsea and be in the premier league
we're talking to rebecca lowe she is the
host of nbc sports the premier league
coverage and the season licks off
tomorrow
okay
hit the wrong letter
very little yes yes it licks off
like yeah we'll be licking off in the
studio no no no no no no no no no carry
on fritzy fritzy is very dodgy is
so dodgy so dodgy by the way so so
um the reaction to um
the saudi investment fund buying
newcastle
and you have the live live tour like is
there any kind of
moral compass that's pointing towards
the premier league going what are we
doing here
yeah but i feel like that for newcastle
united who are owned by that group
they're delighted that liv has come
along because live tour is now taking
all of that
flat because newcastle i think were
bought in i want to say christmas
time-ish and they took a lot of flack
there were protests there were all sorts
of problems there was lots of the other
clubs getting angry saying what's going
on here and they kind of rode it out and
then live came along so they're
delighted so at the moment and i
wouldn't say that football's moral
compass is particularly strong
it comes out every now and then um at
the moment we've all just forgotten
about it newcastle united how you know
this is what happens everyone moves on
to the next thing and the next thing is
live so newcastle are going about their
business spending their money and
looking good this season by the way and
that's going to be the story not who
they're owned by but couldn't they spend
whatever they wanted they they could no
no there's a there's a cap there's a
financial fair play you have to
you have to spend
there's a certain ratio with what goes
out of the club and what comes back in
so you can't spend
a billion and only take in 200 million
you can't do that you used to be able to
when abramovic turned up at chelsea and
even when the city owners turned up you
can't do that anymore it's called
financial fair play so they don't they
try not to let that happen so newcastle
have a little bit of a cap add on to
that they have what's called a newcastle
tax so if you if newcastle go to a club
and say i want to buy your player that
club's going to chuck on another
10 15 million because it's newcastle and
they know they've got the money kind of
a luxury tax like we have in yeah the
nba yeah yes yeah did they take away
abramovitz's yacht did he lose his yacht
i think the yacht is still moored
somewhere but i mean i don't think he's
been on it i mean where is he don't know
nobody knows where he is don't know
where the yacht is but i think the yacht
is still in his possession yes i missed
the
football club though of course owned by
another american you guys are obsessed
with the premier league down patrick you
started it all you and me that's what
i'm saying but is there up is there
pushback though
from
from americans to the american owning
and coaching and
where are you
okay so we are a lot better than we were
so now because liverpool are owned by
really good owners and john henry in the
fenway group sports group um and it's
gone so well and their recruitment has
been brilliant and they've won tons of
trophies the perception of american
owners has changed that thank goodness
because at manchester united there were
problems arsenal have been problems um
but that that perception i would say led
by the liverpool ownership group has
changed um so no there's no push back on
the new owners of chelsea todd bowley
seems to be doing a good job so far he's
made some big changes he's very hands-on
he comes with a good reputation so so
far no pushback uh in terms of coaches
yes and that's because we can hear them
speak we don't really hear tom burnley
speak but when a jessie marsh talks in
jesse marsh's accent which is your
accent
it's so unusual still it's a bit like
when i started my career as a woman when
i spoke i mean i was just absolutely
hammered i was just abused like you
wouldn't believe because it was jarring
to the whole generation of football fans
it's the same with jessie marsh when he
speaks and he talks about offsides
plural offsides and we're trying to tell
him
you know and there's a few things i mean
he's trying bless him and i don't want
him to change he is who he is and he
knows the game inside out it's a
brilliant coach but unfortunately there
will always be as there always are in
life people who don't like new things
right
does your son teddy have your accent or
your husband's
so he's a hybrid and he definitely says
banana but then he'll say other things
in an english accent he will use
american words so we now are talking
about trash we're talking about trunk
and candy um as opposed to
what are your as opposed to rubbish
that's what are you going to put out the
rubbish not the trash and the boot
is
the boot not the trunk
and sweets not candy so he has like a
whole different vocabulary but i want
that i don't want him to be different
i'd like him to be american um
but he does have the old english thing
which is going to cause some problems i
think at school because people are not
going to know what he's talking about
i got
i got the list for back to school items
that i'm supposed to buy for him i don't
know what any of these things are you
guys have a whole i'm like what is a
pencil box wait wait run
so you guys have well we call
should i go down this road you call
erasers erasers we don't call those
erasers
you call them something else
well am i allowed to say that that's the
question yeah you can so we because it's
what we call it right so we have a
pencil and on the end of the pencil we
have a rubber a rubber
correct okay
so so
so if
if that's if you're giving him rubbers
going back to school
you're going to be in trouble
parent teacher conference
dan trust me i went to target and asked
where they were has anybody seen my
rubbers mommy
oh
any other advice what anything else that
i can help you with no it's just
everything is just slightly different so
you know what is the blacktop they said
when you come to school you can't run
but you can run on the blacktop what is
a blacktop is it a playground no it
knows
that the top of the asphalt is black
it's the black top to the asphalt
i love america you know you guys are so
specific with the way you describe words
you know like
you go into a house and there's a rug on
the floor you guys call that an area
like it's for an area and then you don't
horse ride you horse back ride because
you're literally on the back of that
it's amazing when you make a cup of tea
you make it in a tea kettle not just a
kettle it's a tea kettle i love you guys
you guys describe everything black top i
love it this is amazing do you regret
trump do you regret becoming american
good luck with the licking tomorrow
and
good luck buying your rubbers
oh god i'm never coming back on the show
all right at least you didn't say the w
i didn't say wanker this time
i did not
i did not
thank you see you later
that's rebecca lowe host of uh nbc's
premier league coverage
i'll talk to her in a year or so
a moratorium
probably we should take a break with
each other you know we should see other
other people i should see other hosts
you should see other tv people